>> Mike: SENATOR RICK SCOTT,
OUR BEST TO YOU IN THE GREAT
PEOPLE OF FLORIDA >> THANKS.
>> Mike: BREAKING TONIGHT,
WHAT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE A
LIBERTY ADVENTURE HAS TURNED
INTO A DEADLY NIGHTMARE FOR
PEOPLE ON A CHARTERED DIVING
BOAT OFF THE COAST OF
CALIFORNIA.
AT LEAST FOUR ARE DEAD AND 29
MORE ARE MISSING AFTER A
DEVASTATING EARLY MORNING FIRE.
CORRESPONDENT CHRISTY O'GORMAN'S
LIVE IN LOS ANGELES TONIGHT.
GOOD EVENING.
>> GOOD EVENING, MIKE.
A FRANTIC SEARCH IS UNDERWAY FOR
MORE THAN TWO DOZEN PEOPLE AFTER
THIS DIVING SHIP BURST INTO
FLAMES EARLY THIS MORNING
FORCING THE CREWMEMBERS TO JUMP
OVERBOARD.
FOUR BODIES HAVE BEEN RECOVERED
SO FAR.
THE COAST GUARD SING THEIR
INJURIES WERE CONSISTENT WITH
DROWNING.
TAKE A LISTEN TO THE DISPATCHER
ON THE CALL WHEN THE DEADLY FIRE
WAS REPORTED.
IF YOU CAN'T HEAR HOW THE
CREWMEMBERS RESPONDED, BUT IT
SURE GIVES YOU A SENSE OF THE
SITUATION.
>> CAN YOU GET BACK ON BOARD AND
UNLOCK THE BOAT -- UNLOCK THE
DOORS SO THEY CAN GET OFF?
YOU DON'T HAVE ANY FIREFIGHTING
GEAR AT ALL, NO FIRE
EXTINGUISHERS OR ANYTHING?
IS THIS THE CAPTAIN?
WAS THAT ALL THE CREW THAT
JUMPED OFF?
THERE'S NO ESCAPE HATCH FOR ANY
OF THE PEOPLE ON BOARD?
>> COAST GUARD ALL RUSHED TO THE
SCENE WAS THE CALL CAME IN
AROUND 3:30 THIS MORNING.
39 PEOPLE WERE ABOARD THE DIVING
SHIP CONCEPTION INCLUDING FIVE
CREWMEMBERS WHOM ALL MADE IT OFF
THE 75-FOOT BOAT NEAR SANTA CRUZ
ISLAND.
THE COAST GUARD OFFICER SAYS
PEOPLE WERE BELOW DECK ASLEEP,
HOWEVER, THOSE FIVE GROOMERS
WERE AWAKE AND ABOVE DECK AND
ABLE TO JUMP OFF THE SHIP, TWO
OF THEM SUFFERING MINOR
INJURIES.
THE GOOD SAMARITAN LET THEM ONTO
THEIR BOAT TO GET THEM TO SAFET
SAFETY.
CONCEPTION SINK JUST 20 YARDS
OFFSHORE AND 64 FEET OF WATER
WHILE FIREFIGHTERS WERE TRYING
TO POINT OUT THAT FIRE.
WE MANAGED TO GET VIDEO OF A MAN
BROUGHT ASHORE ALERT AND TALKING
TO FIRST RESPONDERS.
THE DIVE BOAT WAS ON THE LAST
DAY OF THE LABOR DAY WEEKEND
CRUISE TO THE CHANNEL ISLANDS
ABOUT 70 MILES NORTH OF
LOS ANGELES.
LOVED ONES GATHERED AT THE
HARBOR IN SANTA BARBARA WHERE
THE CONCEPTION WAS BASED, HOPING
FOR GOOD NEWS.
THIS MAN JUST FOUND OUT HIS
BROTHER, A COOK ON THE BOAT HAD
ESCAPED.
>> USUALLY HE'S MAKING BREAKFAST
AT FOUR IN THE MORNING, SO
SOMETHING HAPPENED.
HE GOT OFF OF THE BOAT, HE IS
ONE OF THE SURVIVORS SO I'M
GOING IN HERE TO TALK TO HIM
RIGHT NOW.
>> CALIFORNIA
SENATOR DIANNE FEINSTEIN ONCE
ANSWERS.
SHE RELEASED A STATEMENT JUST
MOMENTS AGO SAYING THE FBI WILL
BE INVESTIGATING.
THE COAST GUARD SAYS AN EARLY
LOOK AT THE BOAT'S RECORDS SHOWS
IT IS IN COMPLIANCE WITH STATE
LAWS AND THAT THE OWNER OF THE